ve todo un proyecto de ley más
restrictivo con el aborto fue el derecho
que aplicó el gobernador de Carolina del
Norte Roy Cooper este sábado
con los obstáculos Y las restricciones
médicamente innecesarias el aborto no
estará disponible para muchas mujeres
particularmente aquellas con ingresos
más bajos aquellas que viven en áreas
Rurales y aquellas que ya tienen acceso
limitado a la atención médica por lo
tanto veto este proyecto de ley
el gobernador Cooper hizo una gira por
todo el estado para concienciar sobre la
necesidad de mantener la norma actual
que permite abortar hasta las 20 semanas
sin embargo a principios de mes los
republicanos que controlan las dos
cámaras del Estado aprobaron una ley que
restringiría los abortos después de 12
semanas además la ley estipulaba que los
médicos deben estar presentes cuando se
administra el medicamento y que las
mujeres que quieran abortar tengan una
consulta personal con un médico 72 horas
antes del procedimiento una forma de
disuadir que vengan mujeres de otros
estados este proyecto de ley ha tenido
la oposición de colectivos feministas el
aborto es atención médica y la autonomía
corporal es un derecho humano y la
prohibición del aborto de doce semanas
viola eso con la mayoría que tienen los
republicanos en Carolina del Norte
podrían anular el veto del gobernador y
permitir que el proyecto se vuelva ley
próximamente